as we sought to better understand the
coronavirus health experts are worried
it could rival the most devastating
health crises in recent decades patients
with coronavirus may have mild or no
symptoms and still be spreading it
they have no fevers they have no cough
you could be unknowingly unwittingly
unintentionally spreading this to add to
this it's believed that the corona virus
is more contagious than seasonal flu any
method was disrupting this cycle of
infection is worthy of our attention
scientists in London who have had
success in testing malaria have an
unlikely method they think could be used
in preventing the spread of Kovach 19
when you have an infection your body
order that's the smells coming from your
body change which is detectable by
mosquitoes so mosquitoes find you more
attractive when you have a malaria
infection and we wondered whether dogs
could do the same the amazing thing
about dogs is they've got an incredible
sense of smell that are very very
sensitive nose and but they are also
able to learn and they can learn smells
so by combining the two we were able to
train dogs to be able to detect the
smell of malaria very very effectively
above the World Health Organization
standards for malaria diagnostic so
there is a very very good chance that
probably 19
also has a distinctive odor and if it
does then I am really confident that the
dogs would be able to learn that smell
and detect them and how do you think it
could revolutionize our response to Co
the 19 having that kind of test by the
book so what are the main benefits of it
would be that we can rapidly find people
who have an infection but don't have any
symptoms so normally we screen people
from malaria when they present with the
symptoms and all of malaria and find out
if they haven't and what dogs would be
able to do with orders is find people
who are showing no symptoms so those are
the people who will carry on a cycle of
infection this is it at very early
stages do you have a timeframe so we're
hoping that within 2 to 3 months we
would have dogs actually deployed and be
being out there working to detect it's
going to be really important that we can
monitor people coming in and out country
or any country really that is and
potentially infected and so a screening
process and to allow us to do that I
think would be very useful this is
really a form of screening a large
number of people
you